shutting me up is never
like
an easy task yeah
having to beg me for more words is not a
problem
it's getting better it's getting better
and the diversity is uh getting there
like there's just not a lot of asian
representation and especially like lgbt
so to have that more and more is is
there you know but it's few and far
between over the last 25 years or so
lesbian representation has been inching
its way toward progress definitely early
on and honestly still even now
it so much of it centers around drama
what was it called on the l word alice's
little map the diagram yeah it's like
everyone who had hooked up with everyone
and how
all the lesbians have slept with all the
lesbians yeah it's funny but it's also
perpetuating that idea of queer people
being hypersexual and queer people i
don't know dipping their toe in the
taboo i identify as pansexual um and
that's something that
i think gets glossed over a lot it
either gets traded in for bisexuality or
gayness i think that like pansexuality
as a term is not super out in the media
um i i can't think of any characters off
the top of my head even within the queer
community i think that like pansexuality
is a harder concept for some people to
grasp or accept i think queerness is so
vast i think
there's opportunity to have more
diverse queer representation media i
think we're starting to diversify how
queerness looks and queerness and other
identities like identities that we share
i don't think it's well represented
because it's not enough we need more
stories to represent them i believe
we're getting there
this is a lot more than we saw growing
up we have a lot more available options
and media and characters that we can
identify with and there's so many people
out there fighting for this diversity
representation and i can see
that i feel like the roles that are
portrayed
specifically with latinx people
are very
pigeonholed right like are very concrete
and very specific right like it's either
very mask or very fam and
not a lot of the times like somewhere in
the middle
i think we need more representation more
queer diversity even like you were
saying in lgbt films there needs to be
more diversity within those films but
also in mainstream media there needs to
be more
diverse queer representation oh queer
representation in media has to show
the negative stories we need the drama
and like
can we just have like hey someone did
this and it was a thing yeah and it's
fine like showing an example of like
let's do this in a positive way right
could it just be like a normal
plot and then the character happens to
be queer yeah or concept
i feel like i've never really seen a
representation of my story in media or
rom-com because my my story's so
uniquely my own think of something where
you have college-age students at the
beginning of the season one character is
cis and then at the end of the season
they are identifying as trans and just
they just happen to transition and
everyone just accepts them like you know
what show's kind of like that though
what's that one that i've been binging
uh euphoria rude
they're multiples
um um good trouble yeah yeah that's yeah
that's really like a really
refreshing series because there's one
particular relationship where one of the
uh the two starts to question their
pronouns and it's such a simple
conversation of hey
i think my pronouns are gonna be they
them yeah and that was it it was almost
like a throwaway at the very end of the
episode and it was handled so
nonchalantly it was beautiful i do
notice that sometimes you do complain
about like the types of queers that are
represented she's like she's always like
why do they always have to show the
femme lesbians
and like sometimes we just want to see
like the unique lesbians of like all
types not just like the stereotypical
like butchie-less or like the fanless i
do love that in shows that we're getting
now that there are actually non-binary
characters we love
our flag means death there is a
character named jim whose
goes by they them pronouns the fact that
everybody on that show respects the
non-binary character pronouns is a huge
step it's just so normalized even in
that show for everybody to just okay
yeah that's their pronouns and that's
them yeah that's them
so good
one thing i would love hollywood to
understand about the queer experience is
that they should be represented
by queer people
there's enough
diversity within the workforce where
straight cis people do not need to be
playing those roles i think straight
actors can authentically
play queer roles as long as they are 100
committed and they respect the role that
they are given i guess my question would
be why wouldn't
producers directors writers why wouldn't
they want the people representing these
stories to be intimately familiar with
those communities like if you're going
to write a script about the queer
community you need to actually know the
queer community so similarly why would
you not want queer directors queer
writers queer actors
representing themselves stop
representing us for us let us represent
ourselves many actors have later come
out who are previously straight have
come out as queer after playing a queer
role so i think that's always important
to keep in mind that um
we can't expect one or the other from
anybody you know it could be an
opportunity not black or white yeah
right yeah and i think it's unfair of us
to ask or uh to be able to dissect every
part of their sexuality or on a spectrum
or be able to even measure that so
in media there's just a lot of stories
about um straight couples and you know
and even the few stories that i do see
that are out there very still very much
differs from my own so no there's not a
lot of representation i have never seen
a love story that's similar to our love
story i have yet to see one i think
often times there is an emphasis of of
the traumas and
the
hardships of being a queer person what
do you call it the fairy tale ending
happily ever after that right like you
know is really not something that i've
i've seen in in media in terms of a
queer love are we happy after is that
what you're saying yes
so saving face was one of the movies
that we both really bonded over actually
and uh i was like yeah that is my
favorite movie first queer
um
asian all asian cast movie for the both
of us i would say yeah saving face came
out in 2004 it was very ahead of its
time yeah alice wu who uh is a godsend
love her so much it's about two
asian american second generation queer
woman and
it's just so good the wine bottle scene
from shit's creek
yes that was where it goes that was the
scene that i used to describe my
sexuality to my mother yeah and we were
just sitting there watching shit's creek
together that scene happened and i just
went yeah that's me
and her mind was blown oh my gosh and it
wasn't until a couple weeks later we
were driving in the car
where she said um
she was like
i'm so glad that we had that that moment
because i never got it until then
and um
that was a moment that i didn't think i
was gonna get
and it came i don't know like 10 years
after i came out or something like that
um it was really special yeah
[Music]
you